let's say we have some object that's
moving in a circular path so let's say
this is the center of the object the
center of the path right over here the
center of the circle so the object is
moving in a circular path that looks
something like that a counter clockwise
circular path we could do that with
clockwise as well and what I want to do
is think about how how fast it is
spinning or orbiting around this Center
how that relates to its velocity so
let's say that this thing right over
here is making five revolutions every
second five revs per second so in one
second it goes 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 it's
doing that every second it's making 5
revolutions so how could we relate that
to how many radians it is doing per
second remember radians is just one way
to measure angles we could do it how
many degrees per second if we did
degrees each revolution would be 360
degrees if we do it with radians if we
do it with radians we know that each
revolution is 2 pi radians 2 pi if you
go all the way around a circle if you go
all the way around a circle you have
gone 2 pi you have gone two pi radians
which is really just you're saying
you've gone 2 pi radii whatever the
radius of the circle is and that's where
actually the definition of the Radian
comes from so if you're going 5
revolutions per second and there are 2
pi 2 pi radians radians per per
revolution then you could do a little
dimensional analysis these cancel out
and you see you get 5 times 2 pi which
gets us so 5 times 2 pi gets us 10 pi 10
pi radians radians radians per second
and it works out with the dimensional
analysis and hopefully it also makes
sense to you intuitively if you're doing
five revolutions a second each of those
revolutions is 2 pi radians so you're
doing 10 pi radians per second one you
want you know you're just going 1 2 3 4
5 so that gives us 10 or 2 pi 2 pi 2 pi
2 pi radians every time you do that five
times in two seconds you're doing 10 pi
radians per second so this right here
either 5 reps per second or 10 PI
radians per second there
essentially measuring the same thing how
fast are you orbiting around this
central point and this measure of how
fast you are orbiting around a central
point is called angular velocity angular
angular velocity and it's called angular
velocity because if you think about it
this is telling us how fast is our angle
changing how fast let me write it this
way speed of angle changing and when
you're dealing it with it in two
dimensions and this is typically in at
least in an early physics course how we
do deal with it it even though it's
called angular velocity tends to be
treated as angular speed it actually is
a vector quantity and it's a little
unintuitive the vector is actually
popping out of the page for this it's
actually a pseudo vector and we'll talk
more about that in the future so it is a
vector quantity and it is dependent the
direction of the vector is dependent on
which way it's spinning so for example
when it's spinning in a counterclockwise
direction there is a vector
the real angular velocity vector does
pop out of the page once you start
thinking about operating in three
dimensions and if it was going clockwise
if it was going that way right over here
the angular velocity vector would pop
into the page the way you think about
that right-hand rule curl your fingers
of your right hand in the direction that
it is spinning and then your thumb is
essentially pointing in the direction
your thumb is pointing in the direction
that the ank that the actual vector the
pseudo vector is going to go in but we
don't have to think too much about that
for our purposes when we're just
thinking about a two-dimensional plane
right over here we can really think of
angular velocity as a it's official term
is a pseudo scalar but we can treat it
as a scalar quantity as long as we we do
specify which way it is rotating so this
right over here this 10 pi radians per
second we could call this its angular
velocity and this tends to be denoted by
by an Omega a lowercase Omega right
there an upper case Omega looks like
this lower case Omega is what people
tend to use for angular velocity so
there's a couple of ways that you could
think about it you could say angular
velocity angular velocity is equal to
change in angle change an angle over a
change in time
so for example this is telling us ten PI
radians per second 10 PI radians per
second or if you wanted to do it in the
calculus sense if you want to say
instantaneous angular velocity and don't
worry about this if it doesn't make a
ton of sense to you but this is just
instantaneous angular velocity it would
be the derivative of it would be the
derivative of your angle with respect to
time how the angle is changing with
respect to time now with that out of the
way I want to see if we can see how this
relates to speed how does this relate to
the actual speed of the object so to get
the speed of the object we just have to
think about how far how far is this
object traveling at every revolution
that it's doing and what we can do right
over here what we can do right over here
let's say that this radius is R so in
every revolution it is traveling 2 pi r
2 pi r let's say this is our meters give
ourselves some units right over there so
the rate of the circumference over here
is going to be 2 pi r 2 pi r 2 pi r
meters and if the if the let's say that
the angular velocity let's say that the
angular velocity angular velocity let's
say it is equal to omega omega radians
per second radians radians per second
and so how many how many revolutions is
that per second well we could go
backwards from what we did over here we
have one revolution is equal to 2 pi is
equal to 2 pi radians and sometimes just
to be clear sometimes angular velocity
is actually measured in revolutions per
second but the SI unit is in radians per
second and so if we want to convert
Omega radians per second into
revolutions per second radians cancel
out we are left with we get omega over
over 2 pi revolutions revolutions per
second but we know how many meters we
get per revolution we have 2 pi r meters
per revolutions
let's write that down right over here so
we have let me copy and paste this so
our angular velocity if we wanted in
revolutions per second is going to be
Omega over 2 pi revolutions per second
Omega is in radians per second if we put
it into into revolutions per second
Omega divided by 2 pi revolutions per
second and then let's multiply that and
let's multiply that times we want to
convert this into meters per second so
how many meters do we have per
revolution well we're going to travel
our whole circumference per revolution
so we're going to have two PI R two PI R
meters per revolution so these two
cancel out the two pi cancels out with
the two pi so you end up getting omega
Omega times R Omega times let me write
the R and white Omega times are meters
meters per second and just like that we
have the magnitude of the velocity or I
guess we could say the speed of the
object as it goes around in a circle so
what we can say is the magnitude of the
velocity I'll specify that by V I want
to be clear this is not a vector
quantity it's not the velocity it's the
magnitude of the velocity or we could
say this is the speed is going to be
equal to Omega times R so the speed so
let me be is equal to the angular
velocity times R I guess we could say
the magnitude of the angular velocity
times the radius let me write that out
in words and I don't want you to be
confused I'm not saying that this is a
vector quantity if this was a vector
I would I would put an arrow right over
there and if this was a vector I would
put an arrow over there and then I'd be
referring to the thing that's popping
out of the page but here I'm just
talking about the magnitude of the
angular velocity and so writing it in
words you get speed speed is equal to is
equal to angular velocity angular
velocity and if you want to be
particularly will say this is the
magnitude of the angular velocity the
magnitude of angular velocity times
times the radius
of the circle that you are going around
and if you wanted if you wanted to solve
for angular velocity you divide both
sides by radius and you get angular
velocity Omega is equal to speed which
we're using V for so this is V is going
to be equal to speed divided by divided
by the radius so we can actually use
this information to do other interesting
things later on but hopefully this gives
you a sense of how all of this stuff is
related